what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the demon slayer story this is the
straight-up climax of this epic final
battle so definitely stay tuned for that
if you enjoy seeing these Demon Slayer
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial ring that
notification bell because you will miss
upcoming Demon Slayer chop reviews if
you don't keep in mind there will be
spoilers in this video we are going to
be talking about the latest chapter
chapter 198 after all now without
further ado let's jump into this crazy
eventful chapter on the cover page we
have the butterfly estate girls praying
for our warriors and their victory moves
on has caused them a lot of grief and
you can see how much they're worried
even though they're not fighting they
are sweating over the outcome the last
thing they want is to lose more family
and friends like Cano and Thanh judo not
to mention that if our Slayers and
pillars don't pull through everyone else
is practically done for we also seek
George or Odin Goku's low brother he too
is praying you know he's praying for
tundra to come through alive and to
carry on the will of his big brother the
manliest firebender in history this
chapter is called the next thing we knew
so you know something very significant
is gonna happen suddenly in this chapter
and we'll see what that something turns
out to be we go back to the fight the no
ski is cutting a slow down Mouzon zemi
to is using god speed which takes a huge
toll on him I love how the mangaka
illustrates God speed it just seems to
dwarf everyone else's movements and they
look like they're moving in slow-mo
however what's such an awesome ability
there has to be a drawback and for sunny
too it's the fact that he's weakening
and one of his legs is failing he
believes his next attack will be his
last one at full strength and so he
brings out the big guns
is any to use as flaming Thunder God the
form he created himself which takes the
form of an epic dragon made of lightning
this was the attack that was too quick
for Kai gaku to even see we've been
seeing conscious fire dragon in recent
chapters but it's great to be seeing
Sonny choose again and the mangaka made
it look so frickin epic of course moves
on in his current state can't avoid it
and get sliced he's
like a demon punching bag at this point
according to Zetas to the slice is not
deep though because his blade has yet to
turn bright red so he cannot do enough
damage does that lead to false any nosce
comes to his rescue attacking moves on
before the demon king of pop can slice
subs any to watching him no escape fight
is truly a treat in every panel he seems
to be in some crazy unpredictable
position he can even execute attacks
while he's upside down which is always
amusing to see then we see Mullins
recently revealed blood demon art that
moves on didn't even use during his duel
against you Ichi as Tantra did last
chapter in DOS he gets paralyzed by the
shockwaves he's frozen in place within
mulan's range thanks who sees him and
knows he'll never reach the place in
time things seemed hopeless until BAM we
turned the page and see Tangier oh come
to the rescue
it seems like his gamble from last
chapter worked stabbing himself with an
itch hidden blade helped him unparallel
himself Tantra uses a move called
burning bones summer Sun which must be
Milan's nightmare if you hate the Sun
the Summer Sun is overkill and that
points to how much more effective Tundra
Sun breathing must be compared to any
other style on a demon the to keep going
at it time shows flames are beautiful to
see and you can bet this is gonna be a
joy to watch when animated Ninja ain't
seen nothing yet
times roll while he's upside down in no
space tile notices that Mouzon cannot
release consecutive shock waves he needs
to generate them first it also probably
takes longer to generate them because
he's being so affected and slowed down
by tomorrow's poison cocktail time Joe
can see clear as day that Milan's limbs
are slowing then my boy Tong Jiro uses
his dragon attack dragon Sun halo and we
see a giant dragon made of fire
surrounding Mouzon I said way back that
I'd love to cease any to antandrel use
their lightning dragon and fire dragon
moves together and here we have them
being used in the same chapter that's
exactly what I wanted to see and it
feels so good to have our three demon
slaying Musketeers here fighting
together as usual things can't just keep
going perfectly and Tundra starts
spitting out blood he creates an opening
for moves on and he's easy prey so in no
ski has to come to the
this fight really shows how important
teamwork is none of these guys would be
alive right now if it wasn't for the
others we have time zero saving in
escape and then in those case aiming
time zero moments later they give it
their all trusting that the others will
protect them long enough for them to
recover and attack again as tundra is
pulling some matrix worthy moves is any
to us watching trying to force himself
up he knows that the attacks are moves
on can't stop at this point it's about
tenacity as we saw last chapter it's
about who's going to persevere the
longest almost any attack is enough they
just can't give moves on and opening to
escape this is a creative way for the
mangaka to show that everyone has a role
to play and can make a difference even
if they're not the strongest even
characters who wouldn't stand a chance
one-on-one against full power moves on
or at this point able to make all the
difference everyone's getting a chance
to shine no one is being Yamcha is any
to remembers his sensei who he loved
like family Santa brings up his sensei's
memory and asks his sensei to give him
the kick he needs to keep fighting this
is a beautiful moment that illustrates
the power of connections in our lives
to paraphrase anime Gurren Lagann even
people who die are still with us in our
hearts and here's a nice was epic sensei
is still motivating him from beyond the
grave his memory alone gives an e to the
motivation he needs to pull through and
attack Mouzon he lands an attack and
goes flying but still thinks he's too
slow nevertheless he's contributing and
tan judo and eNOS K are still going at
it their styles were contrasted nicely
elegant dancing versus crazy cutting
finally moves on lands ahead on a
nosegay and sends him flying into a wall
Zane's who delivers another Godspeed
attack blazing in two moves on but moves
on takes him down one attack after
another and tundra succeeds in pinning
moves on with his sword to a wall tundra
is in trouble now though he can't use
anymore techniques and he's just
worrying about pinning moves on to the
wall and holding him there for as many
seconds as possible by now you know that
the Sun is all but out so we're really
cutting it close here moves on goes to
attack tundra with every freaking
tentacle but best girl meet suti makes
an appearance man I love her and I'm
glad she's back I'm
and last chapter at the ladies including
meet suti might pop up to help and he or
she is
she tells moves on that's enough with
tears in her eyes she calls him an idiot
and rips off his arm muslims facial
reaction to this is absolutely hilarious
then sunny appears from the other side
taking his other arm and tentacles he's
bloody but he's also son of me which
means he can take Zorro esque levels of
damage and survive moves on trapped does
something super gross he opens up his
face and body vertically he's about to
eat Tundras whole body with all of his
horrifying teeth tundra knows he can
back off or Musa might escape so he
stays firm then all of a sudden the next
thing we knew as the chapter title goes
a guru has sacrificed himself for
Tangier oh and thrown himself in the way
of Moses teeth he looks half consumed
already chances are he's not surviving
this and I was really hoping he would I
know
eager wanted to die the feeling moves on
and this is exactly what's happening but
I wanted him to be happy now with me
truly not in some reincarnated future
that may never come after all
Igor's been through this truly is one of
the biggest tragedies still though you
can't help but respect Iguodala he's
done so much in this fight and now he's
bravely sacrificed himself for tangina
we're told that dawn is breaking it's no
longer a matter of minutes but of
moments son of me tells them to hold on
Tundra looks absolutely horrified at
what's happening and we get a glimpse of
the Sun peeking through distant
mountains and that is the chapter this
appears to be it the tragic end of
course it seems like our guys won but
man I really really want an ego to
survive this and right now I cannot see
it happening
whatever happens though he got what he
wanted if he does die he will have died
that feeling moves on which was his goal
let me know your thoughts on this
chapter below and what you think will
happen next we were told that this is
the climax so it's safe to assume that
even if Mulan has some last-ditch trick
to pull the fight is all but wrapped up
we still need to see Nezha Cole reunite
with tundra although and we need to
figure out what is going to happen to
Tadros face I assume he's not going to
have that in fact that
forever but yeah after so many times of
being told that there are this many or
that many minutes until sunrise it's
finally out and man it's been a long and
suspenseful night for all of us but
we've made it through and our Slayers
have come out on top thanks to
everyone's efforts we might see Yomi and
kinda make an appearance - to help put
the final nail in Mouzon scoff and if
necessary we'll have to wait and see the
million-dollar question is is there any
way Mouzon will be immune to the Sun
after all tomorrow's medicines but
chances are he won't he still seems
fully demon with his crazy vertical
mouth body and that is it for today's
review thank you for listening if you
enjoyed it make sure to smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell so you
actually get notified when the seemingly
last few chapters of demon slayer drop a
special thank you goes to our patrons
over on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and Greta a Lola autumn the
world stealers the school bus Theisen
Kirino acquired respect and Pat a heffa
and I can't forget our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Odin
Anatoly Kazansky alpha do angel Cruz
team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
$30.00 beat Ted no Ted shelter Joel
Staunton very Gucci
Jessica Kayla fond Alicia actor Emperor
otaku and JCC wocka thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more rate by going over to
patreon.com/scishow or and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]